[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 94 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am
very well today.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Very, very excited I'm
going to Australia tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, fun.
I'm going to Vegas tomorrow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I think you went.
I think you went.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think so.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, there's no
callers in Vegas.
Maybe there are, I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: You know what?
There are probably
callers in Vegas.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There are
probably callers in Vegas.
Anyway, also very excited
because we have two people
that were in the
BigQuery team before.
MARK MANDEL: Who?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They are
coming to tell us a little bit
about BigQuery, but about how
it's built under the hood,
so that's interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, I just assumed it was
like magic, and unicorns,
and some other things like that.
But apparently,
there's real technology
that powers like cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's unicorns.
There's magic.
And also, I think,
it's called Jupiter,
but that's the network.
And then some
storage or something.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's a weird mix.
So they're going to
tell us all about it.
And then at the end, we'll have
a question of the week, which
is about Jarvis.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so basically I
want to be able to talk
to my phone like Jarvis
from Iron Man, but I need
to build a bot to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: How can I do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I will try
to answer that question
as well I am able to,
which is going to
be interesting.
But before all of that, we have
our Cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So I think this
week, we are going
to look primarily at community
stuff, which is quite cool.
I want to bring to light
a little series written
by a person on our team, Lexi.
He has, for the
last few weeks, been
writing a "This Week in
Google Cloud" blog post.
So if you're looking for
possibly another avenue
to get sort of some weekly news
about what's happening in GCP,
he's got a really
nice little wrap
up medium blog post that
goes out once a week,
everything from different
network performances,
PowerShell cmdlets in BigQuery,
benchmarks to Google perception
APIs, Kubernetes and Istio,
all sorts of other fun stuff.
So it's well worth subscribing
and having to go check out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
really, basically,
like all the cool things of the
week, but way more than that.
And all in written form.
So if you don't want
to hear our voices,
it's a very good option.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
speaking of medium as well,
I will put a shout out
to another person who
wrote an interesting
article that I quite
like, because you know how
much I like to play my manager.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hey, yay.
MARK MANDEL: All I have
is a first name here.
It just says Grace.
Thank you so much for
posting this, Grace.
It's talking about
type providers
in Deployment Manager.
So as you may know,
in Deployment Manager,
you can deploy, say, like a
GCE instance or a Kubernetes
cluster.
Maybe you want to be
able to automate, say,
a very particular
type of GCE instance.
Maybe it has certain
permissions, or certain startup
scripts, or other
things like that.
You can actually
define your own types
so that you can then reuse those
across your Deployment mentor
scripts.
So here, Grace is showing us
how to do that in a nice step
by step blog post.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And to finish, we have
one more cool thing
of the week, which actually
comes from the Tim.
Aja Hammerle, known as
thagomizer on the internet,
has written a
series of blog posts
where she builds a game that
apparently I knew, but I
didn't know the name of it.
It's called Battleship.
For those that do not
speak English that well
or grew up in a different
country, in Spanish
it's called [SPANISH].
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Same thing.
Yeah, it's "to sink
the battleship."
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that makes sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not
to sink the boats?
Whatever.
But yeah, so she
explains a little bit
how she built all of the things,
of course, in Ruby, of course.
It's Aja.
And I think it's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: It is really cool.
It's worth noting that she
steps through all the logic.
But she has a deployment
for App Engine
that is public with an API.
So if you want to
interface with the API
and play Battleship against
it, it is sitting there.
So you can give it a shot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and all of this
is, I'm assuming,
running on App Engine.
So I'm assuming it's App
Engine flexible environment.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, I
would assume so as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with our friends Tino
and Jordan, and find
out all the magic things
that happen underneath
the hood in BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I am
very happy to welcome today
to the podcast the two
gentlemen co-authors of a blog
that we really, really enjoyed
a blog post by the name
of BigQuery Under the Hood.
So we have today Tino Tereshko.
Hi, Tino.
How are you doing?
TINO TERESHKO:
Hello, how are you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Doing great, thanks.
Thank you for coming.
And we also have Jordan
Tigani, software engineer.
How are you doing?
JORDAN TIGANI: Good, thanks.
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for joining us today.
We're going to be talking
a lot about BigQuery
under the hood, so basically
all of the cool things
that make BigQuery possible.
But before we get
into that topic,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself
and what you do at Google?
Maybe Tino, you can start.
TINO TERESHKO: Sure.
Up until about a year ago,
I was on the BigQuery team
working with Jordan and the
rest of the organization,
just delivering features
and making sure we
got the best product possible.
Now I am the Big Data Lead for
a relatively new organization
called Office of the
CTO in Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We actually have an episode
that either already came
out or will be coming out soon.
We're still not sure
exactly what Octo is,
a very, very interesting topic.
What about you, Jordan?
Tell us a little
bit about yourself.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure.
I was one of the first engineers
on the BigQuery project
several years ago now.
I wrote a book about
BigQuery, which is getting
a little bit out of date.
So hopefully this can
help keep people up
to date with the latest changes.
And now I'm the Engineering
Lead of the BigQuery product.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well,
before we get stuck
into the under the hood section,
we have done several episodes--
I think I'm actually
counting about six,
so i went back and had a look--
where we discussed
BigQuery itself.
But for those people who
may not have listened
or just want a refresher, what--
like very high level--
what is BigQuery?
Let's do like the three
minute sort of thing.
TINO TERESHKO: So BigQuery.
BigQuery is, in very
simplistic terms,
is a serverless, fully managed--
whatever buzzword
you want to use--
high level of
automation service that
allows you to store
vast amounts of data
or little amounts of
data for analytics
and then perform analytics
on that data in a SQL format.
So that's in very,
very simple terms.
But when you actually
start peeling the onion,
you see that there is a whole
lot of stuff behind BigQuery,
the compute engine of BigQuery,
the thing that executes SQL,
is actually Dremel, which is
this internal service that
is ubiquitous at Google.
And then we have this
fantastic storage engine.
It's all tied together
for networking.
And really, the secret glue
that nobody ever talks about,
is our scheduler and
the type of magic
that's possible to
sling resources around
from query to query.
That's essentially it.
But our customers really
appreciate the simplicity
of the product and how easy
it is to scale up and down.
And I think, really, the
biggest thing, again,
comes down to the fact
that it truly is no ops.
Its no hassle.
You set then forget
BigQuery, and you just
focus on things that
are important to you.
JORDAN TIGANI:
Yeah, I would just
add that one way
of thinking of it
is a Cloud based
no-ops data warehouse.
And it's a lot simpler--
simpler to set up and
certainly simpler to scale--
than other options.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned something about
Dremel, which is kind of cool,
because I know that Dremel
is a research paper.
Can you talk a little
bit about how BigQuery
came to be since Dremel?
Is it the same thing
just like made available
to people outside of
Google, or is there
any differences in there?
JORDAN TIGANI: It's sort
of an interesting story,
and we kind of didn't
used to talk about it,
basically because there were
some kind of internal politics
things around it.
But essentially a bunch of
us in the Seattle office
had gotten pulled
off of other products
that we were working on because
the site director wanted
us to build a data marketplace.
And so we all got together
in the dining room
of the original
tech lead and tried
to figure out how are we going
to build this data marketplace.
And what we realized was that
you wanted more than like--
in order to be able to
sell large data sets--
and you know we're
Google, we have
to deal in large data, that's
sort of what we do best--
is you wanted more than just
sort of a download link.
And you also kind of--
there's this concept that
when you have large data sets,
you need to bring the
compute to the data,
rather than the
data to the compute.
So what we decided
was we would build
something that would
allow you to bring
the compute to the data.
So you'd give us your data.
The data would sort
of sit in our cloud,
and then you would
run your computations.
And we harness the
internal Dremel engine
in order to make this happen.
And sort of six years later,
we haven't gotten around
to the whole data
marketplace thing.
We might someday, but this
turned into a quite successful,
successful product.
TINO TERESHKO: If
I may add to that,
I think it is true that BigQuery
does sit on top of Dremel
in terms of the execution
part and scheduling.
I think the main
difference is that we
can treat Googlers
much worse than we
can treat external customers.
We can pop them into all
kinds of crazy, weird dog food
that we can't do with customers
that pay us real money.
And that's kind of, I think,
been historically the way.
For example, the
component of Dremel
that's really undergone
really dramatic change
is the actual execution engine.
What's in the papers, no longer
really the case these days.
The new engine called
Dremel X that's
been live for about
two years in production
was really dogfooded
for a long time,
internally, before the
team was comfortable enough
to kind of thrust that
onto the rest of the world.
And the average customer,
the average user of BigQuery,
doesn't really know when they
switched over to new engine.
They just kind of ran a
query, and all of a sudden
it was five times faster.
And that's really
how they knew they
were on the new stuff
instead of the old stuff.
MARK MANDEL: This
sounds really cool.
But let's maybe take
a step back from some
of the words like Dremel and
stuff that people don't know.
What does it look like?
So say I've got, I don't know,
a terabyte or two of data and I
write some SQL.
How does the magic happen that
turns that SQL into computation
that potentially spans
across multiple computers
and does lots of crazy things?
Can you talk us, kind of,
through that step by step?
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure.
It's a little hard to do that
without diagrams and just
by kind of describing the data
flow, but one way, I think,
of describing the
Dremel execution engine
is there's a query master,
and there's a bunch of shards.
And the query master
gets the query.
It parses it, figures
out a query plan,
works with the scheduler,
schedules execution
of the different
parts of the query,
and then schedules a whole
bunch of these shards
to execute that query.
One of the nice things about
SQL is it's very parallelizable.
Where clauses and filters can
all be completely parallelized.
Aggregations can be
partially parallelized.
And they can be
completely parallelized
if you employ a shuffle.
So we have a really fast
in-memory shuffle that
also gets into the process.
The original Dremel,
the Dremel paper,
was sort of a tree
shape, where, kind
of, the filters would
happen at the lowest level,
the aggregations would
sort of bubble up the tree.
But this didn't really
work for complex queries,
where you kind of
would need to traverse
the tree multiple times.
And so now what happens is
rather than a static tree,
the query master will kind
of design a multi-level tree,
whereas in between we used a
fast in-memory shuffle or we,
in some cases, where
we can directly pass
the data to the next stage.
And this allows the queries
to be much more flexible
and allows us to be flexible
in how we allocate resources.
TINO TERESHKO: Let me
add a little bit of sugar
from my side.
So you heard kind of like
the engineering point,
and now maybe the
customer facing point
that I like to think about is.
Imagine you have this big old--
those IBM blue
supercomputers that
used to be famous in
the '80s and the '90s.
Imagine if you had terminal
access to one of those,
and you could just rent one of
those for four or five seconds
at a time and just pay
per second, essentially.
That's kind of what
BigQuery gives you,
like, BigQuery gives you
access to this incredibly
vast supercomputer that Google
manages for you called Dremel.
And you push the
button, and you say,
I want to use this thing
for a few seconds at a time.
That's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So now I'm wondering, you
saying that there is basically
a lot of computers
running this that
even though it looks like
there's only one big computer.
What is going on in
this basically massively
parallelized query that
is sent all around?
And I guess that how
that is actually done,
like that is into the details of
the paper and stuff like that.
But I'm curious about how, like,
how does this actually work?
Like, do you need to have
like a cluster of computers,
like when Kubernetes, for
instance, you create a cluster,
and then you're ready
to start running things?
Does it work like that?
JORDAN TIGANI: As
Tino mentioned,
it's a multi-tenant system.
So it's essentially we host
a number of giant computing
clusters, and everybody's
queries kind of get time sliced
onto some of these clusters.
And we strive to give every
user 2000 slots, which basically
means 2000 units of
individually schedulable action
that they can run in
parallel, so essentially 2000
shards per user.
You might not get that if you
query in a very popular time,
but you should nearly always
get that much execution power.
And that's going to only be
a very small fraction of any
of our Dremel trees, and we
have a number of Dremel trees
that are around the world,
mostly in the US and in Europe.
TINO TERESHKO: And I'll
add to that as well.
Jordan was talking about
just the compute component,
the query, Dremel.
Unlike any kind of
traditional data warehouse,
or data lake product, or
whatever you want to call that,
BigQuery does have separation,
storage, and compute,
which tends to be a
popular term these days.
So query is entirely
separate from storage.
So storage is unlimited,
it's fully managed,
it's really, really inexpensive.
But you can leverage
analytic capacity
on top of that stories
in very elastic ways.
But also what BigQuery
has that's really unique
is we also separate compute
from intermediate state.
So a lot of times, in a
typical similar technology,
keeps state in the nodes that
are processing themselves.
BigQuery does that.
But BigQuery reserves
the right to keep state
and what Jordan referred to
as this separate in-memory
shuffler.
This allows us to do all kinds
of really interesting things
when it comes to
efficiency and performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
now I'm curious about--
you're talking about the
compute set of things
and then the storage
set of things.
And for the compute set
of things, basically
what we're doing is we're
running-- rather than running
one really big query, there
is thousands of them, like,
or I don't know how many.
But many, many of those
little jobs running
all around that big query tree.
How are those managed?
We had an episode on Borg.
Is this running on Borg?
Is this running on Kubernetes?
Can you talk about this?
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes.
So they're running on Borg.
We also have our own scheduler
to sort of deal with when--
to redispatch queries
that, you know, maybe--
or part of a query was
running on a shard,
and that shard dies--
to recognize that and
redispatch it elsewhere.
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah,
the scheduler also
kind of makes you immune from
any kind of individual hardware
downtime.
The scheduler knows when
something is happening,
and we'll try to reparallelize
the workload and things
like that.
JORDAN TIGANI: And Borg
is what's responsible
for-- if a machine dies or
if one of the shards dies--
it'll restart it and
rejoin the cluster.
TINO TERESHKO: One distinction
I want to make here before
[INAUDIBLE] is any kind of
typical similar technology,
when you stand up a cluster--
quote, unquote--
you essentially have
a process that is really fast.
Automatically, it
goes out and puts out
sticky notes on a bunch
of hardware that says,
this is my hardware right now.
And BigQuery does that per
job very, very quickly.
This process that puts
sticky notes on hardware
executes in less than a
second at massive scale.
And then once the query is
done, all those stickies
are thrown away.
So it's per job rather
than per getting
a cluster going type of thing.
That's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And something you
definitely alluded
to earlier talking about.
So we've been talking
about the compute side,
and sort of on the
storage side, is there
anything particularly special
about how BigQuery stores
the data that enables it to
parallelize in a great way
or able to affect
the performance?
Or is it--
I'm just going to
assume it's not
just a hard drive sitting on
someone's computer under a desk
somewhere
JORDAN TIGANI: So we use our
own proprietary columnar storage
format called Capacitor.
We looked at a bunch
of open column formats,
including Parquet, which
is really, really common
in the open source community.
And there wasn't anything
that would give us
enough control over how
the queries are executed.
For example, in some
of the metadata,
it's arranged in a way
that the query engine has
to do very little work
in order to satisfy
a large part of the queries.
The hash tables that we built
were sort of already pre-built
in those headers,
and we followed
a lot of research papers and
showed us some state of the art
ideas that people had
and productionized it
into our storage format.
So yeah, each column is
stored in a separate chunk
of the file, and this
allows many databases
to use column storage.
Now I think we have a pretty
advanced version of that
that builds on top of the sort
of the standard column store
and allows us to A, compress
better and B, read less data.
MARK MANDEL: So I'll ask
the pertinent question.
What does a column
store actually give you?
Like, what's the benefit there?
JORDAN TIGANI: If you
imagine a record store, where
you store a full
record, and then
the-- the first record
and the next record,
and then you try
to compress that,
that's not going to
compress very well,
because compression works
on eliminating redundancy.
And the redundancy that
you have across a row
is pretty small in general.
But usually, in a column,
there's a lot of redundancy.
Maybe you have telephone
numbers and the prefix
is always the same.
Or maybe you have countries, and
there's only like 10 countries
that you deal with.
And so these tend to
compress very nicely.
The other thing you
can do is, especially
if you're using a distributed
file system where you're not
worried about the speed
of one spinning disk,
is that you can read--
in a column store, you can read
different columns in parallel,
because they will end up--
under the hood, they will be
stored on different disks.
So you get a faster
effective I/O throughput
by reading these multiple
columns at the same time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And I guess that
this is also why,
from the point of
view of a customer,
BigQuery doesn't charge you for
the columns you do not read.
It is because you
actually do not read them,
so there's no compute
cost to send it to them.
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes, exactly.
So yeah, you save on reading the
columns you don't care about.
And in fact, yeah, that was
one of the original reasons
that Dremel was created,
is because there
was an engineer who
was doing a lot of map
produces over these log
files, and these log files
had actually hundreds
of thousands of columns.
But he was only using a
couple of those columns.
And so he was reading
all of this extra data.
And so he just switched his
data to a columnar format
and wrote a little SQL
engine on top of it.
And that's sort of
what then became Dremel
and then what became BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I have a story
that I heard that I don't
know if it's true or not.
But I heard that
Dremel was created
when those map producers
that you were mentioning
were actually taking almost
24 hours to complete,
to process 24 hours on logs,
which is a bad place to be.
Is that true or is it just like
a story that someone told me
just to brag a
little bit about it?
JORDAN TIGANI: That's
absolutely true.
And the engineer who created
it was basically-- he
created it while he was
waiting for his map producers
to finish.
TINO TERESHKO: It had
every major innovation.
There is a very lazy engineer.
MARK MANDEL: I love the
fact that you're like, yeah,
so he just put this
thing together.
It's like a columnar thing.
And then he put a SQL, like
it's just like yeah, it's fine.
He did it in like a couple
of afternoons, whatever.
And I'm like, what?
JORDAN TIGANI: I think
that's just sort of a, like,
an interesting way that stuff
often can develop at Google.
Not to plug Google too
heavily, but he started it.
It wasn't a big deal.
It was a tool that he
wrote, he wrote himself.
And it required a lot of setup.
And he hired him--
they had an intern, and the
intern started working on it.
And then a couple of
the 20% project people
started working on it.
And now we've got dozens of
engineers and Fortune 500
companies relying on it.
TINO TERESHKO: And
they like to say
that at Google, the
hard problems are easy,
and the easy problems are hard.
So we built this massive
supercomputer engine
that just churns through data.
But for the longest
time, we had people offer
into approximate counter
state, for example.
And that was just kind
of, like, the nature
of this organic buildup.
And because of Google
Cloud, we actually
have to care about customers.
So now we have what
the standard calls for.
JORDAN TIGANI: And
yeah, it did lead
us to do some things
that, in retrospect, we
wouldn't have done.
Tino mentioned the
approx count to state,
where internally
folks were like,
well I'm doing logs
analysis, and I don't really
care if there's a million and
17 distinct users or a million
and 19 distinct users.
They really all kind of
fit into that same bucket.
And the algorithm
to compute those
is 10,000 times faster
to do it approximately,
so I'm just going to
use the approximate one.
And there are some syntax things
as well that we were like--
that made it easier
to process your logs,
but once we're trying to get
people who have been using SQL
all their lives to adopt it,
they found some frustrations.
Luckily, both of those
things have been fixed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we've
talked so far about compute.
We've talked a little bit about
storage, about how we store,
but not where.
So I'm curious about where
do we store all of these?
Is it, like, local disks?
Is it in Google Cloud Storage?
JORDAN TIGANI: We store it in
the basement of building 42.
MARK MANDEL: I've been there.
It's nice.
JORDAN TIGANI: No, we
started in Colossus.
So Colossus is our
distributed file system.
The Google Cloud Storage
also uses Colossus.
Things at Google tend to be--
new innovations tend
to be sort of built
on top of older innovations.
So like the technology
stack tends to be very deep.
Google Cloud Storage is
built on top of Blobstore,
which is built on top of
Colossus, which uses Bigtable,
which uses Colossus.
And BigQuery stores
data on Colossus,
and Colossus takes care
of transparent encryption.
It takes care of encoding.
We use an erasure encoding
so that the data is
stored redundantly.
Basically there
are some checksums
that are stored elsewhere.
So if there are failures that
happen on any particular disk,
in any particular chunk,
those can be recovered.
And it's actually sort
of an elaborate kind
of web of checksums that
can be used to recover
from lots of failures.
And so our data
is actually stored
quite durably within
a particular cell,
and the cell you could
think of as a building.
And then the data is replicated
to multiple locations.
So we replicate to a
couple of different cells,
a couple of different buildings
within a region, actually.
So the GC, the Google
Cloud terms or zones--
we upgraded a couple
of different zones
within the region.
And then we also store an
off region copy of the data
to make sure that in case
there's a fire, or a hurricane,
or something, that your data
is still durably stored.
TINO TERESHKO: Again,
what line with how
BigQuery works-- you don't
know if any of that happens.
It just kind of like--
it's a benefit you get.
And
JORDAN TIGANI: Also,
just to make sure,
we don't replicate your
data out of the country
that you're storing
your data in.
So if you say you're
storing your data in the EU,
we don't replicate
it out of the EU.
If you're storing
it in the US, we
don't replicate
it out of the US.
TINO TERESHKO: Here's one more
thing I want to say about that.
Because Dremel is
this big thing that
has lots of compute
sitting around,
and sometimes it's
variable capacity demands
on this compute.
Sometimes it's not 100%.
Actually, a lot of
times it's not 100%.
So we essentially have excess
capacity on the compute set.
So what sometimes
the storage engine
does is it looks at how the
data is stored physically
inside of the query and says,
well, maybe it can be better.
Maybe this table is driven
by 10 million small files,
and we can kind of coalesce
that number down to 10,000.
Or maybe we can do some
other improvements here.
And again, this also
happens without clients
knowing about it.
You just kind of get
potentially better performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Now that we've discussed
two of the three topics
they wanted to discuss.
But we're almost
running out of time.
So I wanted to just
go really quick over
to make all of this happen, for
real, you need a good network,
I'm going to assume?
Could you talk a little
bit about the importance
of the networking these.
Like, you're sending a
lot of data around, right?
JORDAN TIGANI: There's
some bits in here
that are proprietary that
we don't usually talk about.
But I think that one of the
real advantages that Google has
is the quality of its
data center networking.
It means you can move data
around anywhere within the cell
extremely quickly, and the
total throughput of that
is in the pet of
it range, which is
pretty massive amount
of data, and it's also
what lets us often
compete in performance
with in-memory databases.
Because the kind of
performance that we get,
people would assume
you can't get with just
regular old spinning disks.
Because we were able
to A, parallelize it
into so many of
those disks and B,
our network is so fast,
that the overall throughput
is extremely high.
And it's higher than you
could likely get elsewhere.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, unfortunately,
we are running out
of time a little bit,
well, actually quite a lot.
So we are going to
have to wrap things up.
Before we go, I'll give
you the quick opportunity.
Is there anything that
we happen to have missed
or maybe there's an event
or information that you
think people should read?
Basically these last minute
thing you want to make sure
is on the podcast,
what can go there?
Tino, why don't you go first?
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah, I feel
like that blockbuster role was
about a year and a half ago.
So it probably bears
actually expanding on that
and talking about other
things that BigQuery has,
like the data sharing capability
and the in-memory shuffle
a little bit more, and
all the other things.
But otherwise, yeah,
thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Jordan?
JORDAN TIGANI: And
I'm going to be
speaking at the @Scale
conference in San Jose
at the end of the month.
And I'm going to be talking
about the BigQuery storage
system and kind of going
into details, the more
detail than we've shared before,
about that how that works
and why we want to have
our own storage system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, thanks to both of
you for joining us today.
I really appreciate you taking
the time to hang out with us
and tell us all about
how BigQuery works.
TINO TERESHKO: Thank you.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thank you.
I love talking about
BigQuery, so thanks for--
thanks for asking.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
again for having
such a fantastic conversation
with us, Tino and Jordan,
telling us all about all the
things about how BigQuery
works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I still think
it's just magic and unicorns.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, there
was still so much more to cover.
But we had to stop
it at some point.
But super interesting.
And let's remember
that there was also
a blog post that they
wrote a long time ago.
So if you want more
detail and more references
the blog post will be
linked from the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool.
So question of the
week, I want, like,
the sentient robot type
thing, Jarvis, like Iron Man.
I want to be able to talk to
my phone and make it do things.
Tell me how this is possible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So if you follow me on Twitter--
which, by the way, you should--
I've been learning a lot
of machine learning lately.
And so the way to
do this is first,
you need to do some
signal processing.
So you need to know,
like, the basics like
for your transformer and stuff.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Then you're going
to need to develop probably
convolutional neural network--
maybe recurring, I'm not sure.
to be able to understand that
to the speech recognition.
And then from there, you need
to do the natural language
processing, which also uses
convolutional neural networks,
now actually more recurrent
neural networks then
convolutional.
It's not super hard,
just like basic calculus.
So that is a way.
And actually, if you want
to build it by yourselves,
you can totally do that.
There's a different way,
which is to be more high level
and that I recommend, which
is to simply use Speech API.
We have a natural
language processing API.
So those work really well.
And you can build the
whole thing from scratch
if you want to.
Or even better, you
can use something
that is designed specifically
for this use case, which
is api.ai.
And api.ai is a
super cool thing,
because it is a very
simple platform that
allows you to use machine
learning even though you
have no clue of how
machine learning works,
which is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Because
I have no clue.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have
a little bit of a clue,
but I'm still very lost.
And basically what you do is
you define what we call intends.
And those intends are much
in between the text you're
receiving and the
endpoints on your backend.
So at the end, what you develop
is basically just a rest API.
And you're going to get like
JSON messages sent there,
and you need to
respond to those.
So for instance, if you
want to develop, like,
I don't know, like a store,
you're going to have search,
and buy, and stuff like that.
And then you just give examples.
So those examples, for
instance, you could say,
I would like to buy, I
don't know, Pixel XL.
When you say, I want to
buy a Pixel XL, what you're
going to say is Pixel XL is
an entity and I want to buy
is a use case.
And you just give a
bunch of examples,
like saying, well, if instead
of receiving, I want to buy,
it was like I would like to get.
Well, it's kind
of the same thing.
So just give a bunch of
examples for the same intent.
And that's it.
MARK MANDEL: It
sounds like this would
make a really good episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I really
believe so, and I'm actually
going to be speaking about it
during the Cloud summit that
will happen in Sydney, which
I think is on the day this
episode is coming out,
which is Wednesday--
so that's going to be fun--
which might be like Tuesday
in Australia or something
because you have weird days.
MARK MANDEL: It's going
to be the same day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
that's not how it works.
But anyway, it is really cool.
And actually I've been playing
with this a little bit.
And I open source a little
framework for those that
would like to do this and go.
It is super simple.
And I built a very
straightforward application
to do a search on Google Flights
directly from your phone,
and it works.
Unexpectedly, it works, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Well, if anyone
from the api.ai team is
listening and want to
come on the podcast--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, we have--
I have so many
questions to ask them.
So m if you are a product
manager, or an engineer,
or whoever at api.ai and would
like to be on the podcast,
there is a formal invitation
right now, for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, awesome.
All right, Francesc,
before we wrap up.
So it sounds like you're
going away for a while?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounded really bad.
I believe you're traveling
soon to go on a trip.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes,
I'm going on a trip.
So I will be going to a bunch
of different Cloud summits,
basically.
I'll be a Cloud
summit in Sydney,
which will happen on the 13th.
On the same day, there's
also Cloud summit in Seattle.
I will not be in that
one because traveling
across the world takes time.
So I will not be in Seattle.
I will be in Sydney.
And then a couple
of weeks later,
I'll be at Cloud
Next Chicago, which
is on the 27th of September.
And then a couple
of weeks later,
I will be at Velocity London on
the 17th and 18th of October,
then at Cloud Next Paris
on the 19th of October,
and then at DevFest Nantes
in Nantes on October 20th.
And after that, I
don't know, I'll
take a break or
something because it's
going to be very intense.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yep, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So what day does this come out?
OK, cool.
So I will be at Austin
Game Conference on the 25th
of September speaking.
I will be attending
Strange Loop,
one of my favorite
places in the world,
on the 28th of September.
In October-- I really
should book some flights
to Australia--
because I will also be there.
I'll be there speaking
at DevFest Melbourne,
as well as at Game
Connect Asia Pacific,
and probably puttering
around at the very least,
at Unite Melbourne, as
well as Pax Australia.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
busy time of year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's going
to be an intense
couple of months.
And then it's going
to get even worse.
So yay.
MARK MANDEL: Brand new year.
Soon it's going to be 2018.
How terrifying is that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and episode 100 is coming.
Anyway, something
will be coming.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, something
will be interesting.
Cool.
All right, well, Francesc,
thank you once again
for joining me on this
wonderful episode today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]